the undergraduate directing program at
Carnegie Mellon is one of three or four
that I know of serious schools in the
country that grant a Bachelor of Fine
Arts in directing we're looking for that
broad range of experience from
everything from the highly trained arts
high school student to the student who
is out in a the lone voice in the
wilderness creating their own work when
I came as little 18 year old me I had no
I had no real directing experience over
the four years I've really figured out
what my what I'm interested in
artistically it's just a really
interdisciplinary sort of program the
first two years and then junior and
senior year you get even more in-depth
work with all the other options because
the director directs the show their
senior year our students take to at
least two years of acting classes and
which we feel is extremely important we
do our best to create as many design
experiences for our students as possible
so that they're learning how to
collaborate with designers all the
junior directors go to New York for a
semester and either assistant director
observe in new and off-broadway or off
off-broadway theater so you just get
exposed to everything that's out there
because of the rigor of the training and
the way of thinking about different
roles and leadership it allows the
student who graduates from our
undergraduate directing program to
pursue a wide variety of interests one
of the things we feel very strongly
about is we are creating leaders a
director is a leader a director is the
center of any any theatrical production